hello and welcome to felix wardrobe a
new series 20 parts at least we got
Marzia on the camera are you zooming and
don't zoom in
I decided I'll do it like a good why am
I doing this
help no it's not so this is my closet
like it might this closet a little
bigger but yeah I don't know maybe you
probably don't care about what clothes I
have but I thought I'll do it anyway so
here we go Oh welcome to my closet we
got all kinds of stuff where should we
begin this one well that's my that's me
underwear
okay well up here we have two I have two
underwears left we have to do laundry
might say otherwise I'm gonna have to go
cowboy I also have these which is like I
don't know why I saved this do you
remember how long I've had this this is
one of those things that stayed in the
wardrobe along with my underwear
probably soaked up all my ball sweat
sorry should I wear it for the sake of
the video well look cute let's check out
the next drawer all my socks yes you can
tell neatly organized I'm a very
organized soccer person moving on do you
want to check out my socks just one
alright I'll pick one my fit well it's
not here oh I this used to be my
favorite pair but now I only have one of
them but it's got like a little tongue
on it you can always leg okay next up we
have very organized as well I didn't
clean before this I know everyone else
just cleans and they're like oh oh it
just happened to be like this well I
have all my watches got my baby G which
we got in Japan I'm not really too much
into water well you have to have some of
them you know this one it looks
expensive but it's not it's Vivienne
Westwood yeah it's probably the nicest
one I have but oh yeah the poor smitten
one
it's a bit it's a bit feminine but I
like it anyway I don't know I know some
people they spend a lot of money on like
one watch but for me I'd rather buy a
lot of different watches and then just
use them I you get bored of watches and
like no matter how much you love a wash
you're gonna get blown over so I'd
rather get different ones we got them
pins if you cool like me you gotta have
pins always add pins they a little pug
can save an outfit you know an artist
can can't go wrong with that we're
talking about is this like the girl from
Bob's burger I have a lot of black caps
listen they're they're good it's always
good hey Amin good ol mean this one is
from lazy oh if I got it for free I got
this one for free and I got this one for
free and I got this one for free and I
got this one for free but you never know
when you need a cap you know what I mean
when you got a bad hair day not today
though I like them small I believe
they're moving on to my pant collection
it goes look at this boy that's right I
always just wear these pants these are
from urban black skinny pants you can't
go wrong with it especially when you got
legs like these you know what I mean
looks really nice on the buddist wall or
does it I don't know actually
did you just zoom into my but I have
this pair of black as well but Edgar
this is all Edgar it just soaks up Edgar
I can't worm I've got a nice pair of
sweatpants from puff it's always good to
have like a nice pair just feeling lazy
just throw them on fashion can go with
any outfit adidas sweatpants as well
they looked like proper nice pants but
really they're just [ __ ] sweatpants
got a cool little back pocket very
Japanese I think with my style a lot of
it is like Japanese
or Asian or Korean fashion or whatever
I'm probably wrong am i I don't know I
don't know what I'm talking about it's
not like I know anything about these
things
oh yeah and I have these Islam they're
so weird it's like snowboard fabric or
whatever it's like this weird fabric
where they're so comfortable moving on
to my shirts which I never wear this one
is cool I got it recently got the same
problem with [ __ ] Edgar everywhere on
it and it's ethical I care about ethical
clothing might say you told me like
about ethical clothing or whatever so I
don't 90 percent isn't but if you have
one piece that is you feel like I made a
possible impact of the world oh yeah
this jacket it's so cool
finally it's summer and I can wear it
properly it's from one of my favorite
brands it's here see here is he hair say
heresy but is white like it's begging to
just get destroyed and having a white
jacket it's got this cool back hair I
really like it it's a really dope really
cool so now it's getting hot out I can
finally wear stuff like this I don't
know it it's it's still cool it's like a
new season now like I feel like I need
to update but this is a from race by
wolf it's a Canadian brand it's street
wear cool stuff I really like it you
wear like a maybe like a long sleeve
underneath I think that looks really
cool same with this one I love this one
it's so stupid and weird but awesome at
the same time from binti Andrews I mean
it's got birds on it
it's way oversized I guess it's just
what was supposed to be like a dad shirt
in a way but it looks [ __ ] cool and I
love the fabric I literally never washed
it
it's like it's that kind of is that it
sounded weird it's that kind of fabric
all right don't judge me what else do we
got in here
oh my weed my mustache that's not
looking to dad what I've been looking
for this cop top of the morning to you
laddies a lot of you been asking about
this slide this is so cool it's it's
here see again and they I think they're
like two two guys that used to be like
illustrators and then they wanted to
make a fashion brand and I think that's
you can tell like they make cool designs
like like this that you would normally
see I think they have their vision I
like it
it's very cool you probably tell I
really like like long-sleeved shirts I
think it looks good this one is from
catch krasnova
she's a really cool like she's a tattoo
artist and she does like she doesn't own
merch this is too small for me you
should you should have it March to him
you want it good catch oh my god that's
so much shirts my t-shirts got it it's I
have to constantly like sell stuff
because I can never fit stuff in here so
we sell whatever I have extra is selling
deep pop for charity so it's always like
maxed out and it's like oh yeah I'm not
wearing that I got to replace it with
some of my favorite here here's another
one it's also from bindi Andrews a lot
of you guys complimented on this one
America it's like a double layer shirt
it's really cool I love oversized type
of clothing yeah and I got this one from
lazy oh they dont sell it anymore yeah
this is what don't hug me I'm scared and
they dont sell it anymore I'm really
glad I got one got this one from you
know you know they sound like really
weird Japanese style you got a rep team
sesh
oh yeah so wrinkly I'm gonna be morning
t-shirts for a while don't judge me okay
this one is from doomsday it's a British
brand i really recommend checking them
out I think they're really cool they do
like cool prints they're sort of like
tattoo inspired I think a lot of if I
had to describe my closet it's like
Japan Sweden tattoo wannabe hipster
there's too much to show let's move on
to the sweater good ol oversized hoodie
thank you sirens they come and get me
this one my mom bought for me it's so
embarrassing yeah but it's really cool I
don't think she knew it was from sadboys
which is like young liens rap group he's
got a cool style I was like a job mom
you're actually cool and she's like yeah
I knew it was sad boys it's cool I
really like it this sweater is so
[ __ ] cool you got me this one it's a
race by wolf again I I want to get more
from them but they're from Canada and I
just have to pay taxes every time I buy
from them it's just it's not worth they
raced by wolf hooked me up please okay a
lot of just hoodies everyone is always
like oh he's always just weighing Stussy
all right I have two students see
hoodies and I needed hoodies and they
have cool hoodies okay
then I'm not sponsored please sponsor me
Stussy please I have to okay calm down I
haven't - there's two of them and a
couple pants and a t-shirt and a belt
whatever this one I got in LA it's so
cool
I never get to wear it I never wear it
the guy that sold it to me I really
liked because I didn't know the brand of
this sweater and he was like oh so you
don't know the brand and I was like no
and he's like you sir are an awesome
person and I'm like thank you I'll buy
this sweater he was wearing it too so I
felt like a little copycat but whatever
another from the man this is your
favorite Vinci and rose again he makes
such [ __ ] cool stuff it's it's so
oversized it's ridiculous like if you
wear it the first time you feel stupid
but it's so cool when you wear it I love
this sweater
we'll never sell it like this sweater so
I don't know now I know what you're
thinking hey Felix how do you look
outside
well another lot of people gonna hate on
me but I wear a man purse and I'm proud
okay what up I got all kinds of [ __ ]
here wallet dog toy vape Jesus got my
okay pin got my tarot cards for no
reason
Skeletor let's put Skeletor on that
[ __ ] yes some when we were in Japan I
noticed all the guys was wearing their
bangs like this like it's a thing
apparently so
this is from Japan Porter it's yeah
Tokyo Japan I love it it's so convenient
if you're a guy no shame okay no shame
in a purse and all the way all you can
always just slide it over you know and
you're like yeah I this is the most
expensive thing I have it was like 800
pounds yeah it's probably not worth it
but I just I really like that it says
John on it my name is John it's cool bag
it's a cool jacket I had to get it okay
I always just wear these I really just
have one pair of shoes they're nice
garages a lot of people don't like these
I don't know why I think they're so cool
I've had other shoes that are way nicer
but they're just so easy to put on I'm
not gonna bother putting on other shoes
so this has been fashion school with the
Felix a puta Pat if you need any fashion
tips just let me know at any time you
know I've know pretty much everything
I'll link to whatever I use down here I
have no idea of this is entertaining or
anyone gives a [ __ ] hope I don't seem
like I'm trying to like I know anything
about anything is just I didn't really
used to care about dressing up at all
for like a very like my whole life and
then I think I think when I got my
tattoo I was like yeah it's kind of nice
to present yourself in a way does that
make sense
that's it let me know if you enjoyed
leave a like or whatever and brofist
[Applause]